salut mes gars vous êtes mouillés
tous les aventuriers du monde sont déjà
réunis ici et toi tu joues comme une
enfant métier c'est que je ne rate
jamais une occasion de me divertir
voilà
la clique d'où la raison de ce remue
ménage qu'est ce que tout le monde
s'attend à trouver que s'attend à
trouver tout le monde j'en sais rien
mais sur la recherche du temps que d'une
le temple à mes fils s'ils n'ont pas vu
à la télé ça veut rien ce temple fut
bâtie par alexandre le grand qui était
grec au cas où l'un d'eux vous
l'ignorent alexandre a déniché des
splendeurs dans le monde entier ils les
entreposait dans deux endroits la
majorité a atterri dans sa bibliothèque
en egypte mais les pièces les plus rares
et les plus convoités se trouvait ici au
temple de lune par décret nul ne fut
autorisé à consigner son emplacement en
330 avant jésus-christ le temple a été
révélé par les eaux déchaînées détruit
par un volcan en éruption englouti à
jamais en tout cas jusqu'à hier
même s'il ne restait que la moitié du
temple intacte ça resterait la plus
grande découverte depuis les pyramides
les autres se dirigent tous vers cette
zone le long de cette faille d'après le
sens des cours oui
si vous agace ça c'est la raison mortara
c'est un relevés géologiques effectué
deux heures après le séisme l'épicentre
se trouvait ici à cinq mâles sont au
reste de notre position mais
regardez le nouveau relevé des courants
lune cette faille
attendait ils sont déplacés mais alors
pendant qu'ils cherchent tous ici les
ruines se trouve réellement
tout juste
en othe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tibari soucieux
d'abord alexandre le grand refuse que
l'on archives les coordonnées ensuite
dieu provoque une éruption landes au
fond de l'eau
aujourd'hui même les courants
changera
peut-être que ce temple ne doit pas être
trouvé tout ce qui a été égaré et
appelait être retrouvé
te fais pas de souci
[Musique]
il
tiens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
beaucoup plus
e
price où tu en es j'ai même pas encore
téléchargé toutes les images de la
caméra
j'en avais trouvé des traces de ce globe
j'ai pris la liberté de chercher
l'inventaire historique du temple de
lune ne fait mention d'aucun globe vous
allez me faire la liste du moindre glop
jamais mentionné dans l'histoire grecque
tous les globes grecque
l'europe présente
quelques
milliers d'ouvragés
ces milliers d'ouvragés nous les lirons
commencer par celui ci
[Musique]
il plairait peut-être à ces messieurs de
boire un thé pour patienter il s'en
passeront les invités et planète et les
intrus eux prennent la portent
lara ces hommes travaillent pour le mi6
oui et ça se devine alors ma manucure et
leurs costumes impeccables ces gens se
limite à prendre les décisions et confie
le sens du travail aux autres je n'ai
strictement rien à vous dire cet homme
s'appelle cello
lui et son frère etienne sont à la tête
d'un gang chinois connu sous le nom de
celle et ils font dans le trafic d'armes
de diamants d'antiquités tout ce que tu
chesneau peut revendre au marché noir
ils vous ont suivi pas à pas dès votre
arrivée à santorin où ils ont tué votre
ami gay c'est couler son bateau pourquoi
pour ceci après que vous ayez été
repêché une trajet en poste à malte a
intercepté ce fax il a été envoyé par
chen lo à un dénommé johnattan reiss le
scientifique il a reçu un prix nobel